السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان
لا اله
الا
الله اشهد ان
محمدا رسول
الله
الله اشهد
ان
محمدا رسول
[Silence]
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الصلاه
[Silence]
حي على الفلاح
حي على
[Silence]
الفلاح الله الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا اله
الا الله
[Silence]
الحمد
لله الحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه
ونستغفره ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن
سيئات اعمالنا من يهدي الله فلا مدل له
ومن يدلله فلا هادي له واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله وحده لا شريك له واشهد ان محمدا
عبده
ورسوله صفي بخلق وحبيبه بلغ الرساله وادى
الامانه ونصح الامه وكشف الله تعالى به
غمه وجاهد في الله حق جهاد حتى اتاه
اليقين اما بعد فقال الله سبحانه وتالى في
القران المجيد فرقان حم بعد اعوذ بالله من
الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم يا
ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته ولا
تموتن الا وانم
مسلمون ثم اما بعد ان اصدق الكتاب كتاب
الله تعالى وخير هدي هدي محمد صلى الله
عليه وسلم وشر ام محدثها
وكل محدثه بدعه وكل بدعه ضلاله وكل ضلاله
في النار رب اشرحلي صدري ويسرلي امري
واحلل العقده من لساني يفقه قولي اللهم لا
سحل الا ما جعلته سحلا وانت تجعل الحذن
اذا شئت سحلا ولا حول ولا قوه الا بالله
العلي العظيم الله ربنا وقتنا ورجاؤنا
ومولانا
الم
وعمير الله
[Silence]
عل
وس اللهبه
[Silence]
عليه وسلم حديث ما كل الناس يق فباع نفسه
فم
معتقها between
expi
anding by of hum
‏the wise are those ne
deviate defi andal and
composed
states they at the of cre and lord
asking him for forgiven and for their
religious and world affair and their fam
and their that is because
[Silence]
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله
سمعي وبصري وجعلهما وارث مني
الله محد ى الله عليهم
عسن
عبن عب
اللهه
الله رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم يا عس
رسول
ع رسوليه
الله سبحانه
وتالى ابو
بكر صل الله الله عليه
وسلم حج س اللهف والعافيه ف احد لا يؤتيه
بعد اليقين خيرا من العافي او كما قال
عليه
الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم حبيبه رض الله
عنها ولو سالت الله ان يعفيك من عذاب في
النار وعذاب في القبري لكنا خير لك او كما
قال عليه الصلاه والسلام
ح
ض ى الله عليهم
[Silence]
الله عليه
وسم as
حديث رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم الدعاء
المخ
العباده
heuse mindful
رسول
اللهفي
ex الل
اغفري وارحمني وادني
وقن for me mercy upon me me gu me
and this is the most powerful of
supplications that there
is we are in time being the heat
[Silence]
9.
لام حسن ض الله
عن اللد في هديت وعافي فيفي
رول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
يهل عليه
الل العف والعافيه
فيدين في الدنيا والاخره اللهم نالك العف
والعافيه فييني ودنيا واهلي ومالي اللهم
استر عوراتي وامن روعاتي واحفظني من بين
يدي ومن خلفي وعن يميني وعن شمالي ومن
فوقي واعوذ بك ان اقال من تحتي او كما قال
عليه الصلاه
والسلام
انر عن
[Silence]
‏my
حث رول الله صل الله عليه
ولم
askit الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
رسول الله صلى الله علسلم اللهم خلقت نفسي
وان تتوفاها لك مماتها ومحياها ان احييتها
فاحفظها وان اماتها فاغفر لها اللهم اسالك
العافيه
‏life
ifuse الل الحمد الذ ر عل روحي وعافي
وعافني في جسدي واذن لي بذكره
‏in islam is considered
asep inl
small and the reality the world is we
don't know when our time is
coming we of take for gr we
[Silence]
رسول الله ى الله عليه
وسلم صح مسلم السلام عليك اهل الار من
المؤمنين والمسلمين و وان ان شاء
الله لاحقون واسال الله لنا ولكم
العافيه us as
people
my السلام
‏reas
the peace upon init place
[Silence]
الله الله
سبحتى
take i'm not
here
you
you that come
‏but i remind you to take is
the الله
سبحانى in
all whether they are worldly affair they
are religious affairs they are your fam
your
inherit your
jobs your
‏buses all
that and even when down to for the small
death and wake up from
small
ask
incl remember come after
canare
make those
اقول ما تسمعون واستغفر الله لي ولكم
وسائل المسلمين زم تستغفرون ان الغفور
الرحيم الحمد
لله الحمد لله الواحد الاحد الفرض الصمد
الذي لم يلد ولم
وم
احد
for
take
over love
‏difficult
time me and my
family inde been a very difficult time
for
me i don't think go
by when i don't think about
my myer
‏and
accept part of you
doesn't i never the opp
[Silence]
‏first
‏think
bl requ all you toar
things learn
how
and ‏ie this several places in
travel and i say this to same the im are
there but it's not their job they are
your loved ones the
pain and the feelings that you have
nobody can show that the way you ask for
nobody can replicate
it so teach in your
household how to salat
‏how
toing thead how
the what you need to do and what are
the you know i often when i have no
words to say i often use poetry to
describe how i feel
[Silence]
ودت ودعتي
وصفو الحياه واني لا
اودعه كن تشفع به لا
افارقه وظر حال لا
تشفع كم تشفع بيوم رحيل ضحا وادمع مستهلات
ولا ادمعه لاكذب الله ثوب الصبر منخرق
عليه بفرقته ولكن
رقعه اني اوس عذري في
جنايته بالبين عنه وج جرم لا
يوسعه رزقت ملكا فلم احسن
سياسته وكل من لا يوس يسوس الملك
يخل ومن غدى لابث ثوبي نعيم بلا شكر عليه
فان الله
ينز اللهم اهدنا في من هديت وعافينا في من
عافيت وتولنا في من توليت وبارك لنا فيما
وك شر ما قضيت انك تقذ ولا يقضى عليك انه
لا يذل من واليت وتبارك ربنا وتعاليت
اللهم نسالك الخير كل عاجله
واجله ما علمنا منه وما لم نعلم ونعوذ بك
من من شر كل عاجله
واجله ما علمنا منه ولا لم نعلم اللهم
نسالك من خير ما سالك عبدك ونبيك ونعوذ بك
شر ما عاذ بك عبدك نبيك صلى الله عليه
وسلم اللهم نسالك الجنه اللهم نسالك الجنه
اللهم نسالك الجنه وما قرب اليه من قول
وعمل ونعوذ بك من النار ونعوذ بك من النار
ونعوذ بك من النار وما قرب اليه من قول
وعمل ونسالك ان تجعل كل قضاء قضيته لنا
خيرا يا رب العالمين عباد الله ان الله
يامر بالعدل والاحسان وئ القربى وحش بركر
بغي يعيذ لعلكم تذكرون شكر الله العظيم
يذكركم واشكره ويزدكم واستغفروه يغفر لكم
واتقوه يجعل لكم من مخرج من امركم مخرجا
وقيم
الصلاه الله اكبر
الله اكبر اشهد ان
لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محم ممد رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر
الله اكبر
لا اله الا الله
[Silence]
‏st st
اعتدلوا سد
الخلل صلوا
صلات الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين بسم
الله سبح اسم ربك الاعلى الذي خلق
فسوى والذي قدر فهدى والذي اخرج
المرعى فاجعله
غثاء
احوى سنقرئك فلا
تنسى الا ما
شاء
الله
انه يعلم الجهر وما
يخفى ون صرك
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت
الذكرى سيذكر من
يخشى
ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى
النار
الكبرى ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من
تزكى وذكر اسم ربه
فصلى بل تؤثرون الحياه
الدنيا
والاخره خير
وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف
ابراهيم وموسى
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين بسم الله
للاف قريش
ايلافهم رحله
الشتاء
والصيف فليعبدوا رب هذا
البيت الذي اطعمهم من جوع
وامنهم من
خوف الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏pleas
‏take have gr
ination
that
not
requ give generously so take
care
foris ان